bella tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
video allora io vi dico parole forti
verranno utilizzati in questo nostro
scherzando vedo che c'è un piano abbia
censurato un po di roba però questa è la
partita di amgas blu incazza che io
abbia mai visto la mia vita
buona visione darà to impostor among us
di fare una partita decente ragazzi
anche la crew mail allora oltre che a
farla da imposto or vediamo se scappa
una roba decente anche di qualità allora
il problema dei ragazzi che non fanno
mai della loro vita le tasche io vorrei
io per dio sono io le sono velocissimo
che nelle tasche non so come mai la
gente non riesce mai chiesta cosa
nessuno che mi fa almeno quella
emergency ok grazie all'ok electric
watch è un corpo morto io io ero su per
avere ero ok perché oggi a questo punto
dovete scusare lì in mezzo davanti a
real se fatta in questo momento va bene
non si può se skype schiavo non fate
raschi e fatele tasca mia la gente vuole
lenta fa le tasche spero di trovare il
prossimo
nichi e nikic è rimasto lì fermo mi ha
inquietato tantissimo non l'avevo mai
visto prima mai proprio allora quali
devo fare tessera che stanno facendo
tutti per dire che ho detto allora
chissà chi sta giocando da incursore sto
giocando abbastanza bene
quindi secondo me che palle tavolo
insomma io stavo correndo in telecamera
per andare a vedere cosa fosse successo
però aspetta ecco stava in admin con me
io sono uscito e qualcuno ha ucciso e
non lo so era lì era da un'altra parte
raga io dovremmo alla camera io l'ho
visto lì però non so se effettivamente
era la farmacia dove c'era il numero
raga dove c'era il numero martino sta
dimostrando però in palio per un secondo
me canova umano io ti pare
secondo me che non erano neanche a me la
ragazza perché eravamo in più ma che non
è possibile io sono anch'io avrei detto
martina io sono uscito dalla stanza
non so come martina stati sospettano
anche a me anche a me sono io
guarda io non ho parole veramente
l'altro impostore se ne posso andare a
fare perché così brutto pezzo di fatti
una vita
anche noi un imposta la sentivo al 2015
anche dire che non c'era lei stava tutta
allora aspetto minuti all'emergency come
perché ho e charlie o e cesca sicuro non
parlerebbe mai così a me ad esempio che
noia quindi non parlerebbe mai così a
persone che non conosce quindi non può
essere uniti non può essere gente non
può essere gente che non canta nei bot
sentito parlare di doppia di botole
anch'io ragazzi ragazzi ragazzi allora
se nome che noia ha sbloccato perché
voleva palesemente una doppia e
quell'altro non l'ha fatta quindi le
voci dagli inferi bilancio mamma e
charlie sono stati insieme tutto questo
frangente di partita è stato l'aspetto
sindone vista ci siamo incontrati allora
è già in dopo che io sono passato per sé
chi volete perché perché perché ragazzo
che non accendo dovrebbe essere così ma
essendo qui a fianco a me ci siamo
parlati detto io sono ricolmi me
raggiunto
inizialmente il tempo e siamo anche
rimasti chiusi a un certo punto entro se
io decido io vicino potrebbe essere all
addio bhatti che lo stesso
poi secondo me la terra allora ferro che
votatemi però perché conferma che c'è un
voto ancora di no ok però ferma non
votare subito
ok quando muoio potrebbe anche non siete
michele abate potete bardi ma potete
buddy dovremmo e baldi però poi ho
chiarli io lo dico dall'inizio ragazzi a
meno che si possa votare adesso la
prossima io sto male
all'inizio vabbè ma se single man
migliore nuovo demo dove 50 per cento
nick e abbiamo circa 900 o badia charlie
charlie perché io quando è partita da
quando è partito il round visto che è
rimasta ferma probabilmente perché stava
cercando di sabotare qualcosa della
mappa dall'altra pace noi l'anno rimasta
però perché stavo messaggiano suo top
però ecco mi stavi festeggiando allora
marco il mio collega e cosa vi stavate
di nox che mi ha chiesto continua rhinos
invece voterà infatti bravo bravo bravo
sporcherebbe così dice ebadi marmont
tutti guarda io intero tagliandi
staccati raga io non vorrei sbagliarmi
ma ho visto ba di uccidere allora fatto
report ma uccidere farebbe però subito
raga ma chi sono
magari sembro io mi fido di ciò che
diceva alla di prima
perdiamo ve lo dico ricordiamo in 2 2
contro 1 bene vi fa fuori subito
ciao rega ha giocato benissimo
bravissimo bravissimo baldi ha giocato
una partita pazzesca
non puoi mai perso ti fa fuori che cazzo
una moglie bellissima partita avrei mai
sospettato di batini ma va a cagare
vavolo fare impostore io oggi sono in
vena di accusare pietro come sempre
davvero allora fratelli veroli fa una
partita priva di colpi di gomito non so
parlare italiano già fanno lo 2 un
attimo un secco quanta roba c'avevo da
fare in electrical cioè tutto io sono
l'elettricista il primo target come vi
ho detto è dei soggetti è morto ho
beccato il corpo di marci in
communication communication
avete visto che non si fosse allora io
ho visto marcia ancora vivo in
navigazione e poi sono oltre l'unica
persona che ho visto intorno era john a
destra con me io non si chiama lei
dietro dietro i rami in 23 c'era c'era
lei non ho io sono falsi giro quando
partito il fatto tanto sicuro che le
istituzioni visto niente
impara che non so bene
ma non vedeva previsto da noi sono io so
io sono io subisco mostra ma va bene
così vabbè vabbè dai ma io lo terrei
quantità sky messo che noia ma porca
vacca perché deve farle le partite 8
milioni in tasca
domani non si chiedono scattare ma non
penso che come non ne sono sicuro io non
ho sonno perduto sondando regalo doppio
report di ecco io lo terrei sempre
comunque quindi non avevo dubbi
ok non era è così ricco di piano non era
infatti io non saprei chi votare
io ero detto ieri con me e allora perché
mi accusi non ti ho accusato detto ieri
con me allora dato che non ho visto
mando ok allora chi devo votare io voto
lando perché io non ti ho visto e
piccone alla propria vita
io sono stato in medica alle coppie
io sono tutto a sinistra e poi scattato
l'allarme e sono cominciate a scendere
copiosa di lei in cambio non lo so non
lo so però pezzi non so giocare
abbastanza ora vedete no ti prego se
martin ha annunciato e no martina
marzia carmando
vabbè
giuro che mi sia piaciuto ragazzi mi
piace e ci vediamo cosa mi chiama se mi
diverto sempre un sacco spero anche voi
un bacio scheda canale che chopin
[Musica]